when our friend Tom mcshay is here
because he's gonna show us off a child
of light Ubisoft Montreal creators of
other side scrolling bar Christ a Creole
games like Assassin's Creed and Tom
Clancy stuff at child of light on the
other hand this game is looking much
more like the in the Raymond vein of
video game well one look at it makes it
clear that it's the spiritual successor
to child of Eden obviously because we're
raving crude space-time Tomic che
explain this video game to me it is a
video game that is kind of like a fairy
tale and that you fight wolves classic
fairy tale think so yeah this is well
how much focus is this gonna require for
you because this is like the battle
system but you seem like you're
immediately you're pretty overpowered
this is active Time battle this is like
you can do this in your own time right
this is you don't uses turn-based you're
not hitting button no this is this is
like oh that's I oh no sorry active top
I was literally the antithesis of that
yes this is this is like I'm battle like
a buzz word from some game from like a
decade ago he be yeah final fantasy okay
system and most for our fantasy games
this is the melding of let's say final
fantasy no tech early idea fantasy
grandiere dr. grounder yeah with put but
inside of this side-scrolling de
absolutely gorgeous ethereal storybook
world it's yeah it is it does come out
of the studio you wouldn't necessarily
expect but Ruby stuff does do these like
quiet artistic games sometimes that's
something I really like from them so
what is it a bad child of light
specifically that's got you all gushy
about it it's almost the opposite of
gushy so it's really quite quiet inside
and contemplative and it's just like
interpretive and it's just like very
different from the time of stuff that I
normally play and I normally see and I
just really got into it I thought it was
gonna be because it's colorful yeah I
thought it'd be one of them
light-hearted you kid games and I love
those too but it's not like that at all
it's like really somber terms of like
the minutes
or the story that's the tone okay
telling of it like the music and the
artistic design and the story telling me
all that stuff is really just its
melancholy is like the main mood of this
game if you if you got sorry if you got
any questions for Tom at all send them
in via the usual means on twitch at
gamespot or in the game SWAT comment
sorry for saying so the combat is
actually the not like that though like
it is it's really fast paced and frantic
because like so your moves are you're
like you can see yourself at the top of
the bar those are my characters and the
bottom of the bars the enemy characters
and your kind of racing to the end of
the bar to attack okay so it's all like
speed and timing and making sure your
enemy can't attack before you so it's
it's it's kind of a up is that how the
rest of the game feels but I kind of
makes sense too because it's like this
is the one time when like the world
isn't like a sad place this is like when
they're empowered finally hmm yeah and
at the end there's triumphant music but
and now you know it's not just sort of
waiting your turn it's when you move
your little blue Firefly dude you can
like slow an enemy so you're
manipulating where the enemies are on
the timeline and you can if you hit them
during the cast phase you interrupt them
and prevent them from attacking so
there's this there's it like you know
obviously Tom now is sort of playing
with a character that's super powerful
and these monsters are posing no threat
but I've played the first like hour and
a half of the game and you know I
haven't been like smoke down in battle
but it is tense and I do feel like there
is this is this this uh yeah this
tension this challenge to it that you
know II it's a very different kind of
energy than when you're just exploring
the world yeah and it since it becomes
it comes a very dif like interesting
game like your emotions that it did some
questions here goop shoe right asks and
what system is this on your playing on
the xbox one yes I was that was what we
got earlier with Xbox one it's also on
ps3 ps4 pc wii u xbox 360 xbox 360 there
you go wish everything wishful start
which asked Tippy's time which is coming
out on vita can you believe this is not
coming out of veto really because like
this would be perfect on Vita yes Oh
work totally well on Vita and I
I want to be because then I would play
through it and get a hundred percent on
veetle did Rayman legends come out at
the same time as the other releases yeah
okay the reason I reference that for
those who just maybe don't know it's sec
but is it not I don't know if the same
studio but it's the same like engine
engine it's the ubi art framework which
is basically like a developed developers
engine they created to allow artists to
sort of prototype games because it's you
know you it's it starts with the art and
then you take the character and animate
it a little bit and then build the world
around them so if you know you do see
similarities to rate the Rayman Origins
legends games rightfully so it's sort of
the same creative process and they've
got another one announced I think that's
a world war one era a game oh yeah
what's the call again soon it's called
valiant hearts the Great War and I
believe they showed a trailer for it
maybe maybe it wasn't III last year wow
that's not me sometime yeah sometime
between sometime more recently and it
just it's a totally different artistic
style but still has the same kind of
storybook feel really lack of a better
word which is really interesting because
you know it's something it's a kind of
game that you know it's it's action
based too because you kind of think of
artistic driven games and I would think
of like a broken age lucky i'm talking
about before you know an adventure type
game but this you actually have these
mechanics of exploration and combat and
such as that yeah it's it's it's also
kind of interesting to see this stuff
coming out of a major studio as well at
this type of game I want to ask Chris
quickly MNM strangers asking is this an
easy role playing game well like Chris
was saying like on medium I felt I felt
the same way as you were like I wasn't
losing battles but I always felt like I
could move battle yeah you felt
threatened and so it's you don't just
feel like you're I didn't feel like I
was just romper stomper ring and reality
I felt like I'd beat every boss by the
skin of my teeth basically in it and I
wasn't that wasn't actually true but it
always felt like they could beat me at
any time [ __ ] gamers acid does this game
of coop as i get to amaze asked how does
the co-op work so i'm guessing there is
no sir so there is co-op and you can see
that i have that my blue companion whose
not named ignace you
nicholas Nicholas so he comes with me at
all times and I control what the right
stick but if I had a friend oh if I had
a friend my friend would be able to
control that it's a local it's a local
thing it's kind of mario galaxy style
where it's yeah like if you have a girl
I'm cleaning or you have a younger child
or you just you know someone who is
who's interested in this world we
characters in the art but doesn't
necessarily want to do the all the
heavy-lifting like it's a really great
companion well yeah we want who would be
content to let like be like kind of
participant but mostly a spectator yeah
you know like that's a that's a niche
that is not only filled by children well
save hat yes or poor younger siblings
who will never get a chance to play as
the main character because they're older
sibling just one yeah oh we've all been
there ty space Hall asks at those child
of light explain its combat mechanics ah
well at the beginning is this type of
game where you need to have played those
old games no not at all let's this is
very friendly for people who are not we
don't really know those games yeah they
ramped it ramps up really easily and you
know sort of builds these systems of
like you know the different attacks you
haven't you also have spells and you can
also defend and so there's and you know
you also use potions there's more you
know going on there then Tom needs to
employ now but I can't really see the
screen as well with the words so it's
going straight up but I go with the
servants like there's magic she doesn't
like to do different actions take a
certain amount of time and monsters can
interrupt you if you're not careful so
all that stuff you know is is smartly
paste and well explained yeah also this
game is pretty gorgeous i was just going
to say what's going on it's kind of
insanely good-looking it's really pretty
yeah animation on her as wonderful as
well i know it's just such a lovely game
that's so glad that it exists how long
it take you to complete it not to ask us
to my obvious question oh that's a
that's a fun question we could really
get into that you want to get into that
you don't add spoiling anything I think
it took me about 15 hours I play well if
I play this on Vita what it'd probably
take me about 20 or so hours to do
everything okay that while i'm ivan
done everything oh yeah I'm sorry I
would have done everything on video I
didn't have a chance for the review
purposes I it's also just a game I
wanted wait not Vita why would you have
done everything on the Vita but you
didn't on the Xbox whenever my beauty
games is like a hundred percent wow
really it's just cuz you have like a
huge community yeah that's all you have
you because I commute for two hours so
if you're if you're playing on your
personal time basically is what you're
saying yes you would have fun doubt it
yeah I would have hundred percent of
this game and I really wanted it i
really want their hundo and speaking of
Hondo's and Max or madness asked how
much grinding is required none zero
grinding zero grinding I did not grind
it all I in the beginning to bump a
little bit varun oh yeah I I did fight
most enemies that I saw as you can see
that combats kind of optional the most
part yeah I didn't fight with the
enemies that I saw but it is not
grinding it is not like final fantasy 10
that I'm currently stuck in because you
have to grind in that dinner o people
were recommending me that I play that as
a better final fantasy I want to grind
okay so I got to the end boss in that
game and then I had a grind so I don't
know if I'm ever gonna finish that oh
wow the end boss is not the finish of
that game or you have to grind to finish
the yeah I can't like unfinished inbox
that's annoying Wow Canadian sp30 one
asks a question on the face of it maybe
is a little strange considering this
game but then I remember it's made by
Ubisoft will child of light have lots of
DLC I don't know how they were details
me i mean it's it's done and dusted it a
complete story i don't expect to ever
see a sequel I don't expect to ever see
DLC I think this is a singular adventure
that just stands on its own but we'll
say maybe I could be wrong I kind of
just hope it is I mean like that kind of
game how frequent is like platformer dlc
this is not a platformer okay okay
you're right it's it's a two dimensional
like would you call it an RPG secondly
an RPG edit I didn't mention the genre
in my review
it doesn't fit anything okay I didn't
feel as necessary okay now this this is
by our definitions of garbage so what
would what would the dlc then be like
extra little adventure a new area what
was the game added or the epic released
xbox 360 side-scrolling remember that
one up totally blanking out on yeah we
both feel like that remission very much
shadow complex saddle yeah shadow
complex i haven't seen you'll see ya
drops and completely unrelated new genre
different company and didn't have dlc
thanks danny god thanks for making my
job easy tarnish it all right it's like
well then that's the end of the child of
license your review up already yeah it's
up it gave it a neat i think it's great
oh my i'm not sorry to say that was
really a triumph it was great as well as
perfect good and
you